so I'm not going to sort of like rehash
everything that happened during our
vacation but there are a couple things
that I do want to get to one of them is
that Donald Trump appeared to
neurologically malfunction during a
speech for the right-wing on-campus
group Turning Point
USA Donald Trump slurred his way through
this speech he went on a very strange
rant about windmills which I will get to
but the moment that is attracting a lot
of attention and also garnering demands
for a full neurological workup at a
proper medical facility is the moment
where Donald Trump slurred his language
at the exact time that here he appeared
to spasm or twitched his shoulders now
the audio alone doesn't do justice so
we've been playing the video for our
television audience to see let's now
actually listen to it's just a 12 second
clip and let me begin by wishing you a
beautiful they were trying to take
Christmas this is getting very difficult
to ignore to pretend that everything is
fine but once again even if you excuse
this particular moment the behavior the
rest of the speech was odd now as far as
this goes which some people are calling
again a neurological malfunction or some
kind of a spasm I got emails from some
folks saying David the the condition
tardive dyskinesia seems to maybe be a
fit here although when I look that up
it's not totally clear to me that it is
and of course I am no medical
professional even if you excuse this
moment the behavior the entire speech
was odd here's the part where Donald
Trump talked about windmills he's
talking about wind farms he's still
calling them windmills making absolutely
no sense whatsoever an economy based on
wind I never understood wind you know I
know windmills very much I've studied it
better than anybody I know it's very
expensive they're made in China and
Germany mostly very few made here almost
none but they're manufactured tremendous
if you're into this tremendous fumes
gases are spewing into the atmosphere
you know we have a world right so the
word
Taney compared to the universe so
tremendous tremendous amount of fumes in
everything you talk about the carbon
footprint fumes are spilling into the
air it's spilling whether it's in China
Germany it's going into the air sorry
their air everything right so they make
these things and then they put them up
and if you own a house with envision of
some of these monsters your house is
worth fifty percent of the price they're
noisy they kill the birds you want to
see you at birth grade you just go take
a look a bird graveyard go under a
windmill some day it went on from there
I think he referred to China as China
which is really weird he's looking at
windmills very strongly he studied them
very much this is that repetitive
overuse of certain linguistic crutches
that we've observed with Donald Trump
before most people don't know that the
world is tiny compared to the universe
that's another one of his linguistic
crutches that he uses when he seems to
sort of get confused
meandering about where he's going
calling wind farms monsters is just an
odd touch and then here is that that
sort of slowed down slurring from Trump
inclusive of that spasm moment maybe on
the low side so if anybody wants to be a
nice conservative talk show host it's
not a bad living I will say but I have
to say he's a very unique guy he's a
great man and he's been a great friend
so thank you - Raj thank you
and let me begin by wishing you a
beautiful look you remember this you
remember they were trying to take
Christmas out of Christmas you remember
so once again you can say the Christmas
spasm wasn't a spasm that what front
Trump considers comedy in some way well
what about the slurring and the total
incoherence about windmills the question
that's coming up more and more is if
this keeps getting worse if he continues
to seemingly deteriorate what will he be
like by the time of the general election
debates against the eventual Democratic
nominee and maybe maybe more importantly
before our vacation Donald Trump tees
the idea that he might participate in
the debates maybe he would do more
debates maybe he would do fewer maybe he
would do none at all depending on what
he wants he said as president it's
ultimately up to him is all of that
related to starting to lay the
groundwork to just not do any debates
because he would come completely unglued
during a 90-minute debate I don't know
the answer to that Democrats what I do
know is that Democrats would really have
to run someone terrible to come away
looking like they lost the debate to
this guy Trump can barely put together a
coherent thought at this point in time
and I still wouldn't put it past
Democrats to nominate someone that will
make Trump not look that bad and make it
at least plausible that Donald Trump is
holding it together during the debates I
hope that doesn't happen I think most of
you understand what I'm talking about
and what I'm getting at but continued
very bizarre behavior from Donald Trump
call it what you want I do want to hear
from you what do you think went on in
this video
leave a comment if you're watching on
YouTube or send me a tweet at D Pakman I
want to tell you about a really great
YouTube channel we're partnering with
it's called up flip TV and they've just
recently launched they've have some
excellent content for anybody interested
in business and entrepreneurship check
them out at david pakman.com slash flip
that's FL IP that
redirect you to their YouTube channel
make sure to subscribe while you're
there it is a YouTube channel that I'd
recommend to anyone in the David Pakman
show audience who owns a business runs a
business it's thinking about starting a
business or even if you just like
learning new things about how business
works they interview successful
entrepreneurs business owners giving
them a place to tell their stories and
share strategies so viewers can benefit
from their insight and apply their
wisdom to your own businesses all of the
content is about educating and inspiring
people in each video up flip TV
showcases a different type of startup it
could be a coffee shop or a landscaping
business or a real estate agency you'll
see how the business was often started
from scratch what a work day looks like
how to become and remain successful in
that business and they don't just
interview people they actually examine
each business from inside out in a
really unique way that distills the
valuable lessons that you can take from
their stories I find the content
fascinating they're friends of the David
Pakman show I would love it if you would
go and support their new youtube channel
and what they're doing I think you'll
very quickly become a fan like I said
get there by going to david pakman.com
slash flip
that's FL IP and make sure to subscribe
to their channel when you're there